foreign
[Music]
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
I'm Piers Morgan uncensored tonight one
of Britain's most wicked murderers Levi
bellfield was permission to Wed behind
bars in what will be a sickening
ceremony featuring him in a Versace suit
and a pair of them having a Harry Style
soundtrack lawyers say it is human
rights why should a serial killer have
any right by getting married in prison
will debate
Fury of a shocking leap footage of
conservative party staff passing through
lockdown at least two of them were just
granted lifetime honors by Boris Johnson
should those honors now be removed
as a Spotify executive says Harry and
Megan are lazy effing Drifters after
axing their multi-million dollar podcast
deal on the second possibly comment
[Music]
live from the news building in London
this is Piers Morgan uncensored good
evening Fernando welcome to Piers Morgan
uncensored Levi bellfield is a name that
sends chills down the spine of anyone
who knows about him he's one of
Britain's most notorious and wicked and
merciless serial killers now serving two
whole life orders for murdering at least
three teenage girls his victim has
included 13 year old Millie dollar who
he abducted and brutally killed in 2002
a disappearance sparked a frenzied
Nationwide search the galvanized the
whole country behind her devastated
family and to this day he's a stained on
our Collective memories I don't believe
in the death penalty but if I did Levi
bellfield's name would be at the top of
the list the very least of public
expects is he's locked up forever and
sees out his life in something close to
the miseries inflicted on the families
of his victims but instead he's getting
married yeah you heard that right one of
Britain's most malignant human beings is
to Wed Behind Bars everything about this
case is staggering Belfield spent 30 000
pounds in legal aid funded by our taxes
to defend his case they began talking to
his fiancee a woman in her 40s after
spotting a photograph of her in the cell
of Peter Sutcliffe the Yorkshire Ripper
who murdered 13 women he was allowed to
get down on one knee to propose to this
woman in front of the prison guards now
he's being allowed to plan his own
ceremony in the prison Chapel reportedly
she'll wear a white dress he'll wear a
Versace suit they'll listen to his
favorite Harry Styles song this is all
completely outrageous and the government
told us it wouldn't happen the prisoners
minister at the time Victoria Atkins
said this
absolutely appalling I've ordered an
immediate review into this I'm very much
welcome the debate we're about to have
about the Bill of Rights and looking at
human rights for in the United Kingdom
the 21st century and believe you me I'll
be raising this
what happened Dominic Robb the former
Justice secretary said this
what I can tell you is it's
inconceivable that the president of the
ministry of Justice would authorize that
marriage we're dealing with a dangerous
serial killer right so why is he getting
married bellfield's lawyers reportedly
threatened a blockbuster human rights
case against the government if he was
blocked from getting married but where
are the human rights of the girls he
murdered through his deplorable actions
Belfield deprized his victims of the
child to themselves fall in love and get
married the absolute least he deserves
is to be deprived of the same thing
the government must stop this farcical
wedding and if need be have it stay in
court I suspect the entire country would
be with them well joining me now is
Criminal Barrister in King's Castle
Chris door and by the former met police
detective Colin Sutton who caught Levi
bellfield well Colin something let me
start with you some stories just make
you so angry just on sight and this is
one of them what are we thinking as a
country to allow someone like Levi
bellfield to get married like this
yeah I think there's unanimity on this
which is unusual you know that I haven't
heard anybody say that this is a good
idea
um aside from one or two lawyers who
don't say it's a good idea but actually
you have said it's the law he's entitled
to do it and I you know I suspect that
may be what Chris is going to say uh but
it's wrong it shouldn't happen
um to me it's a manifestation of a wider
problem and that problem is that
predatory men who are convicted of
crimes against vulnerable women
are still able to access to speak to to
groom
women from behind bars and I think
that's the The Wider ill that we need to
be looking at this is a man who has
controlled by force and by coercion
every single woman who has crossed his
path as an adult
and we let him carry on doing it from
within prison where he's serving
multiple whole life terms yeah I mean
it's to me it's it's ridiculous all
right Chris from a legal perspective we
know it's currently lawful so let's just
agree that that's the current law but
why is it the law well I think it's the
law because of an understanding that
that there is in our society a certain
um
acts and certain practices which are
available and should be available to
everyone no matter what they've done
even serial killers on whole life
tariffs who are never coming out of
prison but that's the state of the law
as you say that's what the law says it
was surprising that you heard government
ministers who apparently didn't know
that when they were suggesting they were
going to be able to stop it because it's
Act of parliament but what about the
fact that this is a guy who we've just
heard
use coercion and violence yeah mentally
visibility control a lot of women not
just the people he killed
but here we have a clearly vulnerable
woman I mean one of these frankly
lunatic women who get attracted to
serial killers like Levi bellfield and
pretend they've fallen in love with them
and want to get married to them I've
interviewed lots of very dangerous
people in my time for crime
documentaries these women are two are
penny for reasons that baffle most of us
but she's clearly vulnerable she's not a
mental sound mind
why should he be allowed anywhere near a
vulnerable woman given his track record
I think you make a good point but the
difficult of me is I don't know where
you get all that information about this
woman because I'm not aware of all of
that being in the public domain my view
would absolutely be if this woman has
mental health what normal woman would
want to marry to Levi Belfast it's not a
bad question but the point is you say
what normal person would do lots of
things in this world and and I agree
with you I don't understand why any
rational human being would want to marry
someone like this not least because
they'll never get to spend any time
alone together they'll be they'll maybe
allowed an hour to a month in a visits
room and that's the extent of the
relationship but you you you would say
that wouldn't you about any woman who
wants to marry anyone who's in prison I
mean and particularly if they're in
prison for a long time not necessarily
it depends on the crime but here you
have a specific crime of somebody who's
snuffed out the lies of a series of
young women
and also raped and attacked and coerced
and controlled many more this is one of
the most evil people in the country but
who specializes in preying on vulnerable
women and yet here is a clearly
vulnerable woman because you can't be a
sound mind that he's allowed to get
married to that is where the law to me
becomes an ass well for me that's not
about the law at all that's about risk
assessment in an individual case if it's
the truth that this woman is not capable
of giving rational uh open-minded
consent to get married she shouldn't be
allowed to get married but why should
anyone never mind why should anyone on a
whole life tariff be allowed to get
married anyway particularly when they've
removed the option of getting married of
a series of women they've murdered why
should they but you make a good point
but by that rationale you would take
away the right to marry from anyone
who's ever committed a murder of anyone
no no it's not where's the line then all
live tariffs to start with okay so just
people who get your 70 or 80 people well
Pete yeah start with them okay and at
the very next oh then you I think you
look at the k Case by case I mean let me
bring you back Colin here I mean you
were a detective a long time right how
how evil was
or is Levi bellfield
off the scale I mean you know he just
just simply the most evil dangerous
human being I ever encountered but I I
would say what what sort of society do
we have or what sort of legal or
criminal justice system do we have where
we incarcerate somebody for offending
against women when we know all this
about what they do with women and yet we
allow them to contact and groom other
women once they've been convicted yeah I
mean we just I mean don't be Chris do
that we shouldn't let them groom anyone
any more than we let anyone voluntarily
engage in grooming if there is evidence
that there is grooming and there should
be because every telephone call is
recorded every visit is is monitored by
video and by microphones if there's
grooming no normal people
mentally sound woman
that seeks out and for introduced by the
Yorkshire Ripper for goodness sake right
seeks out someone like Levi bellfield to
fall in love and get married she's
clearly sick well you say that yeah I do
say that you say that but but what about
someone who maybe has a deeply Christian
faith and believes in forgiveness I mean
lots of lots of very very religious
people believe in redemption and
forgiveness are you saying that they
shouldn't be allowed to to to take
forward that religious Viewpoint and to
try and find Redemption for someone
because you don't believe in it no I'm
saying that in a civilized society where
a series of young women have been robbed
at their chance for romance for love for
marriage the idea that the perpetrator
of the wicked murders is allowed to do
all that is so sickening that we should
change the Lord to stop it as indeed the
government kept indicating they were
going to do but the problem is you keep
using words like sickening and evil yeah
all of these words they're words that go
back south of years ago it's Old
Testament nonsense what we should be
doing is asking ourselves well you don't
think he is sickening or anything I
don't I don't think evil is a concept I
really I I accept no his Acts were evil
undoubtedly but I don't believe anyone
is born evil I just don't believe if you
perpetrate acts as evil as he did you
are an evil person what if you're a what
if you're a sociopath you have no
understanding of what you're doing
there's no suggestion belfield's
Associated bad he's not a big diagnosis
well it's very interesting that you that
you think that you could do all of those
acts and be of sound what is not to my
knowledge someone who's done those acts
you must automatically be insane well
let me bring back uh Colin as far as I'm
aware Belford has not been diagnosed as
a sociopath or a psychopath who is
completely immune and feelings he just
is to me the personification of evil
yeah I I I I don't think labels like
this are helpful at all I I think you
look at the evidence you look at the
facts and the fact is there is ample
evidence available to show how he
interacts with women and what he will do
to groom and get women uh charm them if
you like at first and then act in a way
that is coercive and is dangerous and
harmful to them and you know we we
listened we listened to every single
phone call he made while he was on
Remount for our offenses that took lots
and lots of time I think the notion that
every phone call from every prison is
actually listened to from beginning to
end is fanciful there just isn't the
style for it they may be dip sampled at
best and you know that what I'm saying
is is that we should we should look at
these people where there is evidence of
their history and their past defending
which shows that they are a danger to
women and we should take steps actively
to prevent them from contacting women
from within their prison I mean I think
that is a very good I agree I'm not
disagreeing with the if you have
evidence that someone has been
manipulated coerced best and subject to
potentially criminal Behavior the prison
service shouldn't allow it any more than
they would allow someone to physically
attack someone in a visit's room if
someone is being damaged by a prisoner
that needs to be stopped but it's a
completely different point to whether in
principle you should change the law
based on this one case to stop a certain
category of murder murder marrying it
needs a wider debate than that and it
needs I think to get away from this idea
that somehow the more harsh and inhumane
you make the treatment and the
conditions in prison the better your
Society will be and the safer it will be
for well our society won't be what well
okay I would say to that our society is
not improved or or damaged in any way by
Levi bellfield being in prison for the
rest of his life it makes no difference
to us on the outside provided provided
he remains a danger to the public for
the rest of it please I agree he's
certainly a potential danger to this
woman right who you seem to think maybe
some God-fearing Christianity I know
nothing about right you told us me lots
about it I've not read that I just know
I've interviewed a lot of serious
killers they all have women like this
you become obsessed with them they're
all in my view damaged and they're all
vulnerable and they're all sick of mind
because how could you possibly genuinely
fall in love with someone you've never
even been with in any sexual way or
physical way and you know the crimes he
committed on other women to me that's
not you know there's no doubt about the
fact they're mentally fragile or or
damaged because what what else could
they be well if a psychologist and a
psychiatrist say that this woman is not
fit to consent then the marriage
shouldn't take place I agree but if
she's fit to do so that's her
prerogative that's her choice yeah but
okay not ours Colin final words here and
I read a little heart-rending interview
I read an interview with the parents of
one of the victims this week and it was
heartbreaking you know I've got a
daughter and it was just the fact that
they felt so robbed of themselves of
seeing their daughter get married and
now to have to read this with the
details the Versace suit the Harry
Styles music all of it it is all and
people may not like this language it is
utterly sickening
yeah it is and I understand that point
of view entirely uh but I I want like
Chris I want the wider thing to be
looked at but perhaps coming from a
different position I think that we
should be preventing we don't know what
this woman how this woman has been
coerced persuaded Charmed or whatever
into marrying Levi Bellville we don't
know what happened in those
conversations okay and the fact is there
is ample evidence that he will charm
persuade coerce and mentally harm and we
heard him doing this while we were
listening to his schools we heard him
doing this to a 16 year old who was his
mistress for one for a better word where
she just obeyed him instantly when he
who he grew until when she was 14 and
that wasn't even one of the cries it was
deemed serious enough for his record
because of all the more serious stuff
which involved murdering exactly that
yeah it's but there are lots and lots of
men in prison in this country for
offenses against women who are still
allowed access to those women and other
women and can still harm them and make
their lives a mystery and that's the
wider issue that needs looking at not
the one-off marriage which happens once
in a blue moon
okay gotta leave it there Colin thank
you very much indeed uh Chris I
understand you're you're just explaining
the law really and that's what it is I
think in this case the law is an ass but
uh that's the problem that's my
prerogative and in a free Society thank
you both very much indeed well from
Monsters to well a [__] is that being
too rude MPS Are Tonight deliberating
Boris Johnson's political future the
commons are debating the report that
said the former PM lied repeatedly and
deliberately to the commons over party
Gates what is British as a Theresa May
has been sticking the boot firmly in
tonight
this committee report matters this
debate matters and this vote matters
they matter because they strike at the
heart of the bond of trust and respect
between the public and Parliament that
underpin the workings of this place and
of our democracy and I also say to
members of my own party that it is
doubly important for us to show that we
are prepared to act when one of our own
however senior is found wanting
well here here I never thought I'd feel
inspired by Theresa May but I was today
she stood up for what Parliament should
be well joining me now has talked to
these political events of Kate McCann's
okay that was a powerful speech it
really was by Theresa May and that was a
leader speech it does beg the question
where is the actual prime minister Rishi
sunak who seems to have done a sickie
yeah I was in the Commons chamber for
that speech and it was a real moment
there was you know complete silence
labor as much as the conservative
Ventures were cheering on Theresa May in
the way that MPS do and I think the
point that she made most clearly was
that this is not about Boris Johnson now
this is about the fundamental way that
Parliament works it's about truth it's
about upholding it and it's about
accountability to the public and so
naturally it follows where is Rishi
sunak because for lots of MPS there on
all sides this is a man who came into
Parliament promising Integrity promising
to uphold those values and this is an
opportunity to prove that why is he
abstaining from this I think the
politics of this were always going to be
complicated for the Prime Minister I
mean while a lot of Boris Johnson's
supporters have exited stage left you
know they've already gone they have
triggered by elections there is still a
rump of the party who don't want to have
that exposed the route between the
current and the former prime ministers
but it's actually quite difficult really
to formulate a reason it would have
given him the opportunity to spring
forward the next election looks very
complicated and difficult anyway so what
do you have to lose I think the reality
is he just didn't want that political
argument yeah but you know what if
you're gonna I like Rishi soon though
but if you're going to stand up for
decency in public life the standards for
ethics as he has laid down his his sort
of flag you've got to turn up for this
and you've got to actually say yes I am
going to vote I'm going to support the
Parliamentary process because I believe
in its Integrity by abstaining you're
saying you don't really go along with it
yeah and that's exactly what a lot of
his own MPS are saying today you know
they are fed up of Boris Johnson and
they would have quite liked actually to
be able to draw a line under it and what
you heard from Theresa May there was
that was the fundamental point which is
that when it's one of our own it's even
more important to Stand Here
particularly as you said if it's one of
the top yes and particularly where it's
been a question of preaching one thing
to the public and doing another Well
Harriet Harman said that if Boris
Johnson hadn't been held to account by
this committee he would have
contaminated she used that language the
rest of government and actually there
was a real moment in the comments today
where Jacob Reese Mark stood up and said
well hang on Harriet Harman you tweeted
you'd already made your mind up about
this committee before you even sat down
and she said and it was you know a labor
MP said mic drop moment it really was
she said well actually I went to the
government and I said I'll recuse myself
if you're worried about that and the
government said no it was the first time
we've ever heard that and it shows that
she had the backing of you know those at
the very top of Downing Street they had
no concerns and I wonder whether that
may play into this too because the
politics of whether Rishi sunak wanted
this committee to find against Boris
Johnson is rumbling behind the scenes
sadly I think it comes down to the
politics rather than actually the
fundamental question of lying to
Parliament and the integrity and we saw
a video at the weekend of precisely what
this is all about which is a bunch of
young tories illegally partying in the
middle of a lockdown and debate that in
a moment but they're right there on
video was also the mindset which we
better not stream this so people see
that we're bending the rules they knew
what they were doing Boris knew what
they were all doing and that's why it's
so shameful okay thank you appreciate it
and says the next anger over that leaked
footage of conservative party staff
partying through lockdown at least two
of them incredibly have just been given
lifetime honors by Boris Johnson in his
resignation of this resignation that was
of course forced through shame ignominy
and disgrace I would suggest those
honors should only now be scrapped the
debate after the break
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to Pittsburgh welcome to my
pack Esther crack who talked to the
contributor Kevin McGuire Associated to
the mirror and the tool to view
presenter Rosanna Lockwood or welcome to
all of you quick reaction on Rishi
suneck not turning up for this vote
I think he just knew the way it was
going to go and didn't want to be taken
down at this point making a comment on
it but I just think that's a real damp
squib actually he needed to let the
country know which way he was going so I
think we could guess why and which way
he would have voted but I don't know
maybe it's just Victorian fighting moral
cowardice Kevin no yeah certainly
cowardly shows he's weak uh and he's
left the heavy lift into others and I
don't think that's leadership a strong
leader is from the front he's what's he
scared of Esther why is it in a line in
the sand I think he's scared of saying
that you know Boris the whole Boris
faction is now has now been marginalized
and the Tories need to accept that but
he doesn't want to do that because Boris
still has a pool with a significant
portion of the conservative there's a
whiff of trump about all this right it's
the same thing in America where Republic
senior Republicans are loath to
criticize him too much just in case he
comes back that's not a basis for
integrity or political courage is it no
it's just it's the opposite in fact yeah
and he I think that's it soon I will pay
a price for it I want to play a bit of
this video this is these uh young Tories
on the Lash in the middle of the
lockdown in December 2020 which really
says it was the first video we've seen
we've seen some still pictures they
don't really tell the whole story this
is indisputably a party yeah and they're
all pretty drunk so he's been going on
for quite some time let's take a look
[Music]
and so he goes on uh Rosanna I mean the
kick your motif of the pub because you
actually hear them say at one stage
let's not stream this because we're
bending the rules they know what they're
doing is against their own rules set by
the conservatives in the lockdown it was
called mingle and jingle for Christ's
sake I mean the way that the government
were telling people to stay in their
homes and not associate with other
people and not make it it's absolutely
galling I showed it to friends and
family over the weekend so what do you
think and somebody said I was having
heart palpitations at about this time my
mom actually said that about going to
collect my sister from London and saying
you know you weren't sure if you're
abiding by the rules or not and then you
watch that video the way they're
behaving these people who no better and
like you said they knew they should I
think I have a bigger issue with this
and it's not just that you know
obviously blatant hypocrisy it's what
information were they privy to when they
were telling the public right that we
should be terrified of code because it
could you know it could kill us we could
lose our lives but they weren't
terrified enough to be doing it it'll
make all those who've been skeptical
about the veracity of the public
statements from the government believe
that they were entitled to feel
skeptical because if it was that
dangerous we all had to be locked down
why were they able to do this you do
knowing it was that dangerous you do you
alienate all of those people and then
you alienate all those who followed the
rules and uh you couldn't go to funerals
see loved ones through Windows instead
of visit them you know who'll forget I
mean that's the image that party was in
concert of the HQ yeah that's where it
was it was in conservative HQ the guy
with the jumper the dodgy jumper he
works in Parliament for a Tory Minister
The Woman in Red is uh on the campaign
of a Tory hortful for London mayor they
should all lose their jobs the two who
uh given honors in Johnson's
dishonorable list uh one you you would
see him in Dodge
you shouldn't get well I don't think
losing their jobs will do anything
like these are dishonorable people being
honored by a Dishonored ex prime
minister I mean Kia stalma has said he
wants he doesn't want to have a
resignation list I agree with him Tony
Bland Gordon Brown labor former Prime
Ministers they didn't have them look it
should be scrapped it's it's cronyism
it's kind of gongs for your mates and
your Chums who will do anything for you
it has no place in a model no it doesn't
okay let's turn to two people that I
think have no place in modern society
Harry and Megan who've been called by
this Spotify executive producer Bill
Simmons on his own podcast this is after
Megan's brilliant podcast was so
tragically uh unceremonically canceled
uh he described him as lazy effing
grifters and then went on to spray gun
them a bit more uh I mean he's got a
point isn't it they've got 20 million
apparently for 12 hours of 12 shows of
half an hour each was that a 12 shows of
half an hour any defense here and you
know I do come in swinging to defend to
Defender Megan and Harry sometimes
because I feel they're in my age bracket
I should but this time you've got not an
impartial voice but somebody who did
business with them saying uh you should
hear some of the stuff I heard from
Harry now he was talking particularly
the Spotify executive about the zoom
call he had with Harry to plan these
podcast episodes and he said I want to
get drunk sometime and tell me how bad
must that is honestly Kevin I know
you're not not a massive fan of the
Royals anyway but this is the problem
with this isn't it if they're going to
do what they're doing and they're just
basically pocketing the cash and not
delivering and all they've really got
this interesting is trashing their
families right or trashing the media
it's one of the two yeah and that that
sticks kind of run us run it's cool it
has like the the book spare was
incredibly successful the Netflix series
was of course because they're trashing
their fans but I think they've they're
running out of steam and look and I've
tried to defend them in the past because
I don't think they all have you run out
of steam too yeah well I think there's
no there's no point if you're getting
somebody at Spotify saying they're
grifters they you know so a legend she
didn't even do some of the interviews I
read that I read that today it's not
been confirmed but there's a podcast
website which is suggesting that various
staffers who worked on it said that she
didn't even do all the interview yeah I
think she's not apparently she's not
going to get the full payment
um of the contracts but look at the end
of the day the Sussex has overestimated
their brand and so did other businesses
they thought they left
all this attention they're big they're
big business but that didn't take them
very far and I think you know the the
sussexes are now rethinking I always
said the money for them was in trashing
their families right you can only play
the victim of the media card so far
before people find it ridiculous given
the way they're using the media at the
same time but the trashing of the family
thing it's a double-edged sword yeah of
course you make millions if you remember
the royal family trashing the Royals of
course you do but then what you've lost
yourself very unlikable you've lost your
families and there's also once you've
done it about five times people get
bored with it the shock value wears off
so that's what that's what happens
after after the thrashing of the
families they're not really people you
want to hang out with in a pub but
doesn't mean I definitely won't be
hanging out with them
this is the culprit though not really
them but the corporations that showered
them were cash oh yeah because their
brand would Outlast that but it didn't
because there's no substance there
they're just not like it was deaf the
people you know the people who gave them
it yeah I agree let's move to uh wix uh
Rosanna the Chief Operating Officer
Fraser London says trans voices must be
Amplified in business he said at an
event organized by Pink news on trans
rights anyone who disagrees with him uh
are bigots who are not welcome in the
Stalls it's fascinating this because
obviously we're in pride month and
obviously this is a company that's
trying to show its alliance with the
pride kind of community and I can get
that perhaps got a little carried away
on this front but I just find it
fascinating that this is a DIY store
that is basically playing morality
police and saying we're going to police
who comes in and out the store based on
them why haven't they learned right
Kevin why haven't they learned from
America where you've seen this now blow
up massively with Target with Budweiser
with all these things all these
companies that are trying to go Ultra
awoke and their fan base just don't want
to hear it thanks yeah if you have a DIY
store and you're slugging off your
customers you must have a screw loose
because
but I think he was trying to be a little
more subtle than he's come across and I
think he he was really talking about he
said most people are kind you know
they're a little confused little
ignorant but they're mostly kind I think
that's right I think there are a few
people who are hard-line bigots on this
issue and there are lots of serious
issues to discuss yeah including women's
that is actually happening now well
exactly that's why my messages company
said be careful because in all your
virtues signaling actually companies are
losing billions except this is a numbers
game right it's really and I hate to be
so crude about it it's not worth
pondering to the 10 trans people in the
UK for for some extra business it's not
worth it yeah but if you show some
respect I think that's what he was
really about wasn't he both as employees
and people coming in what does that have
a place in business the sum of 2020 I
was getting emails from ice cream brands
and I'm like your ice cream why are you
sending me I don't want to hear any of
it and I just want to jump in some
updated breaking news this is this
extraordinary story that there was a a
submarine that went down to see the
wreck of the Titanic and it was 12 12
and a half thousand feet below the
Atlantic Ocean and on board was a
British billionaire called Hamish hard
you run to Big Ovation company this
submarine has disappeared in completely
mysterious circumstances everyone is
trying to find it but they only had 96
hours of oxygen that's down to under 70
now and there's this frantic race now to
try and find this submarine but the
there is a lot of fear they won't be
able to that is just too deep it's too
dark and they'll be very lucky if they
find them but obviously we wish that
rescue operation all the very best we
can that's the wreckage there and it's a
desperate situation for those who are on
board but how Eerie that you have on
that particular submarine trip down to
see a wreck that Infamous and you just
disappear quite extraordinary uh
breaking news story there well thank you
Pat good to see you and says the next
could a Democrat topple President Biden
well one of the hopefuls Marianne
Williamson is here in my studio to tell
me why yes she thinks that the cat
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to peers organization with
Marianne Williamson is a best-selling
author of celebrity spiritualist a
confidant of Oprah Winfrey and she has a
way she'll also be America's first
female president when many Democrats
warning that Joe Biden and simply too
old to run again she wants to outflank
him from the left the more youthful left
you might think and harness love to
defeat Donald Trump and I'm delighted to
see you're here in London and in my
studio great to see you thank you thank
you so much for having me I want to play
you a clip this is President Biden last
week uh ending a speech about gun
violence by completely randomly saying
this
it's the least consequential part of
this whole meeting for you I promise all
right God Save the Queen man
okay well two things
the queen died 10 months ago she's not
our acquaintance yes not your queen and
and our queen died 10 months ago
this is the latest thing involving
President Biden where he just said stuff
which makes no sense actually it's
pretty inappropriate to some people
quite offensive he seems to forgotten
our queen died last year
um and it goes to his mental capability
it's a big issue I mean it can't be
ignored I don't think how do you feel
about this uh you know I think it's for
the individual voter to decide it gets
personal and I don't want to be personal
about this I'm running against the
president on issues uh there are many
people in his Camp who would argue yes
he makes gaffs like this but when it
comes to his decision making on issues
he's just fine every individual has to
decide on that and I think it's kind of
cheap for me to go there
I mean it happens a lot
it happens a lot obviously I wouldn't be
running if I didn't think I'd make a
better president right
um I want to talk about a couple of
issues with you which are in the news
which you have quite strong views about
well I don't want to play you a clip
this is the British prime minister Rishi
sunak who was heard on a leaked video uh
talking about the big trans debate at
the moment hmm
you may have noticed uh Ed Davey has
been very busy uh like me you were
probably seen that he was busy trying to
convince everybody that women clearly
had penises and I was reflecting you all
know I am a big fan of everybody
studying maths to 18. but it turns it
turns out that we need to focus on
biology
so this has become a big thing right
um along with the question what is a
woman there's now a big debate where
British political leaders have been
asked about whether a woman can have a
penis and they've given bearing answers
the British prime minister says no the
labor leader says 99 of women do not and
the liberal Democrat leader who he was
referencing there says clearly women can
have penises on on the face of it this
might seem a strange debate to be having
but what are the answers I mean you're a
presidential candidate well in the
United States I think we are obviously
going through a cultural transformation
people are getting more comfortable with
the notion of gender fluidity non-binary
sexuality for me it's an issue of
Freedom people get to be whoever they
want to be do whatever they want to do
if it doesn't hurt anyone else to me we
have to follow a North star in our
society that North Star is the idea that
all people are created equal if you talk
to me about a trans-american the part
that matters to me is the word American
and so but what is a woman to you
listen it's whatever at this point in in
somebody's culture in in American
culture certainly kind of whatever
anyone says that it is
that it absolutely can if people you say
it hurts people but if anyone can put
their hand up and say they're a woman we
have a situation we had recently where
the leader of the Scottish of Scotland
Nicholas sturgeon of the Scottish
national party she had to resign after
putting a biological male rapist into a
woman's prison so there is obviously
damage there from self-identity isn't it
well certainly that yeah but I think the
issue there was rapists not the issue of
the sexual uh what is the fact she felt
that she felt that this male rape is to
identified as a woman at his trial yeah
that would be horrible right simply to
get into a woman's prison yeah that's
wrong right well yes but then that's
that's once you're talking about
something like rape then obviously it
becomes relevant it does it's not
relevant what about sport well on Sports
I do think we need to protect girls who
were born as girls if they are in a
situation where somebody obviously
because of the size of their of their
muscles and of their body gives them
enough that's all biological names well
yes that's sort of my point so you would
stop well hang on just to clarify that
you would stop biological males
competing against biological females
unless it can be proven there are are
some situations where somebody let's say
that one is a man but they're a small
man right and it can be proven through
hormone testing through muscle testing
and so forth that there is no biological
Advantage but you know the other day I
spoke at Cambridge University and I
noticed when I went into the area where
the bathrooms were that it said use
whatever bathroom you're more
comfortable with and I thought oh my God
it could be that easy so I think
everybody needs to lighten up on this
issue because it's hard to lighten up if
you are say a female Olympic Athlete and
you're losing out on your place well
that's because a biological male is six
foot three inches and built like an
outhouse decides to take your slot by
saying hey I'm a woman which goes back
to your initial thing that you should
all be what you want to be well sure I
want to be you know I want to be a movie
star but I'm not there's a reality check
if you're talking about specific
instances such as Sports such as where
somebody goes in prison Etc then
obviously these become issues that have
to be deciding points but there is
another world out there which it's not
hurting anybody it just has to do with
somebody's desire to identify a certain
way the area where we need to culturally
open our mind to the idea of fluidity in
gender and so forth and both can be true
at the same time well I'm not sure it
can because I don't think you can have
Limitless self-identity without it
infringing particularly on women's
rights to equality and fairness that's
the problem with it and that's why it
sounds great to say of course you can
but then you end up with that ridiculous
woman Rachel dolezel who decides to
identify as black
well if you have Limitless self-identity
why can't you
you know I think that somehow we have to
find that balance in ourselves as well
as ourselves as a lawmaker who wants to
be the first female president of the
United States
what's the balance because you either
allow it or you don't no I disagree with
you as president I think my uh my
responsibility is to the notion of all
people created equal I as president
quite the opposite of what you just said
as president hey I want the whole notion
of of my presidency would be please be
who you want to be do what you want to
do spread your wings and soar if you get
to the point where you're infringing on
the rights of other people you're going
to have a hard time how would you feel
if a uh if a man decided to a male
politician decided to suddenly identify
as female and became the first woman
president of the United States I'd be
like damn but that
wouldn't just be bad you'd be like what
I don't think he'd be horrified but that
doesn't mean I think it would be illegal
or that it's I didn't say it'd be
illegal that's the whole point the whole
point uh Madam would be president it's
perfectly legal I think well that's my
it's just wrong I don't even think it's
wrong it's just we I think we'd all uh
down a few glasses of wine that night we
wouldn't be real happy about it Usain
Bolt wants to run as a woman in the
Olympic 100 meters you're going to allow
it no that's that I I believe that this
thing was Sports we must protect those
who who you know when you see these
girls who were born as girls and they
have worked so hard you know obviously
and I think most people see that quickly
about reparations yes we've had lots of
debates on the show about this whole
issue I I have to admit I come from a
position I don't see why people today
should be compensated for sins against
their ancestors some cases centuries ago
explain to me why I'm wrong because it's
not just about you it's about the
responsibility that you have as a
citizen to the fate of your country and
whether you are an individual or a
nation you're not going to have the
future you want if you don't clean up
the past you know so should I okay but
on that then should I be claiming money
back as someone in Britain from the
Italians for what the Romans did from
the Normans for what they did from the
Vikings from the from their forebears
now should I be claiming reparations
from all of them and if not what's the
difference I'll tell you what the
difference is there is no way that a
modern Brit is being economically
disadvantaged by something that the that
the Vikings did well I think it's been a
long long another might be people in the
middle of Britain no who are still
suffering the Opportunity Financial
injury of the what the Romans did to
their families let me answer your
question it is very obvious that there
has been intergenerational hardship
financially the gap between blacks and
whites that is so egregious in America
today is a legacy not only of slavery
not only 250 almost 250 Years of Slavery
but also of almost a hundred years since
then of institutionalized suppression of
black people this is 300 at what point
do we stop feeling guilty about the past
after we've paid our debt or paying for
the party there's a difference here's my
point it never stops once you once you
uncork that bottle you end up never
stopping you need to let me talk there's
a difference between blame and
responsibility I don't feel I need to
feel guilty my parents came from Russia
and Poland my grandparents so it's not
about my grandparents it's not about my
feeling guilty it is about my feeling
responsible for for the well-being of my
nation Germany paid over 89 billion
dollars to Jewish organizations after
World War that's true and I think that
that Financial remuneration has had a
lot to do with not only the financial
but even more importantly the
psychological and emotional healing
between Germany and the Jews of Europe
and this is a healing that we have not
had that war was over in
1945. Iris was over in 1865 and we still
take this time and we pass it
Generations you make a good point I need
a one-word answer to this question to
wrap things okay should Donald Trump if
he gets convicted of a federal crime and
actually goes to prison the Constitution
says he can still be president of the
United States should he be allowed to be
it's not about the laws the law would it
be disappointing would it be awful for
the country yes but if it's legal it's
legal Marion great to see you thank you
great to have you in London and says the
next claims a covid leak from a lab in
Wuhan used to be heavily censored as a
conspiracy theory now it was all
mainstream Thinking author Michael
schillenberger says he has proof of a
Kobe cover-up and joins me next
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
next on The Talk MPS are still having
their say on the partygate report that
found Boris Johnson deliberately misled
Parliament will update you live and the
race is on to find a Titanic Taurus
submarine with a British billionaire on
board thus Harry and Megan are slammed
as grifters as their multi-million pound
Spotify deal is Scrat that's all coming
up at nine o'clock
[Music]
welcome back the theory that covert
originated in a Wuhan lab was once
considered a dangerous disinformation
worthy of a ban from every mainstream
website to even characterized as racist
now the Sunday Times has evidence that
Wuhan scientists were combining deadly
coronaviruses just as a pandemic began
many Western governments now believe
it's the most likely origin of the
pandemics what does it all tell us about
censorship and about covert well I've
got the perfect person to ask it's
Michael schellenberger who's tearing up
with Russell Brand over here for the
censorship industrial complex exposed
event in Westminster on Thursday Michael
great to see it especially here in
London
covid disinformation
the kind of agreed narratives that came
out about covid have slowly been chipped
away at suggesting that the scientists
weren't always right after all and
they're actually querying science it was
probably a civic duty rather than
something worthy of being expelled well
it's even worse than that we know that
in late January Anthony fauci and
Francis Collins the an NIH heads in the
United States their own advisors when
they first looked at this they said
looks like it probably came from a lab
not from nature several days later they
then reversed their position they got
new grant funding later very suspicious
set of activities our sources tell us
that we now know who the first three
coveted patients or patients zero were
and they were the three people that were
working on this manipulation of stars
like coronavirus they always seemed
utterly absurd to me that you would
discount a theory that you have a wet
Market here but right next to it is the
Wuhan Institute of virology which is
testing coronaviruses I mean why
wouldn't you at least consider it well
neither but we know that there'd been
this long history of lab leagues before
then there'd been a huge controversy
there was a Cambridge working group that
recommended a ban on gain of function
research Obama did ban it in 2014 and
then fauci and his colleagues snuck it
over into China under everybody's noses
as though this was somehow their
prerogative to do it the science like I
say evolved a lot they would say evolved
others would say change some would say
you turned I can remember being quite
sensorious myself about people who've
not had the vaccine when it was believed
because the scientists said so that you
couldn't transmit covet if you had the
vaccine but once it was established it
made no difference actually I felt quite
bad about being so censorious what does
this tell us what is the covid pandemic
tell us particularly in a social media
era well I think the first thing is that
in an emergency you want free speech
there's this idea that an emergency that
somehow we should set aside our normal
Free Speech rules but it shows the exact
opposite reality is changing the virus
mutated and changed and the vaccine
wasn't as effective as we thought it
would be that's particularly the kind of
environment you'd want all this open
debate free speech is something that you
don't just suspend during emergencies
you need it to get the facts out to deal
with the changing environment this idea
that somehow the scientists declare the
truth from on high and give it to the
people that's a religious view not a
scientific view scientific views are
supposed to be debated and contested
publicly the issue with I guess they
would say is look if you dissuade people
from having a vaccine which probably
saved a lot of lives I believe it did
others can have their view but if you
dissuade people through that debate you
may end up killing people and that was
the justification for a lot of censor if
you remember they they were demanding
the censorship industrial complex was
demanding the censorship of often true
stories of vaccine side effects remember
we fought for decades liberals and
progressives in the United States to
require the drug companies to say what
the side effects of their drugs were in
their television advertisements here
they were demanding that those side
effects be censored when ordinary people
were sharing the money so what's the key
lesson we should take away from this I
mean the first lesson is that for us in
the United States we have this thing the
First Amendment it's a sacred part of
our constitution of our constitution we
think that that should be something that
other countries should be embracing more
strongly we shouldn't be defending
ourselves from other countries trying to
impose censorship on us we're in the
midst of a global attack on Free Speech
it's everywhere at UK Ireland EU Brazil
Canada United States we need to push
back against that we need a global
movement that's as powerful free speech
is not sort of a nice to have it's a
need to have for a liberal democracy
it's actually the Bedrock of any proper
democracy without Free Speech you are
not a democracy Michael great to see you
thanks for having a good good luck with
your speech with Russell uh Great
Character uh so there's a lot of
interesting things Russell I want him on
the show put a good word Emily
absolutely great to see you thank you
that's it from me whatever up to Keep It
Uncensored especially your speech good
night
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign